c'est vrai le rire c'est important
marine colombelle vous êtes
psychiatrique et auteur est-ce que ça
fonctionne la rigologie c'est une
approche qui est géniale parce que elle
a lit deux choses déjà le plaisir de
rire on a tous du plaisir mais surtout
le corps ça veut dire qu'on va sortir du
mental on va revenir sur notre corps sur
la sensorialité et on voit très bien que
ça marche très bien avec ses adolescents
qui vont échanger des regards donc tout
le monde en plus serait contagieux il
suffit qu'il y en a un qui commence à
rire pour que tout le monde finalement
ressentent la même émotion dans son
corps c'est un antidépresseur le rire
bien sous forme d'antidépresseurs
merci d'être avec nous
Maxime il y a 50 60 ans on rigolait
jusqu'à 50 à une heure par jour au fil
des années le temps où que l'on met à
rire à drastiquement diminuer parce que
les gens sont on est moins dans le
partage on est plus individuel et je
crois que c'est un impact aussi sur
notre santé mental et de la transmission
ça veut dire que les émotions sont
là soit aux autres pour communiquer et
quand on est sur le smartphone qu'on est
finalement dans notre petit écran on
n'est plus dans la communication donc
les émotions naturellement ont tendance
à être beaucoup ça plus faible moins
forte et on perd le plaisir de l'humain
c'est important bon premier conseil que
vous nous donnez à prendre à respirer
souvent nous dit apprendre à respirer
mais comment il faut respirer parce que
c'est vrai je me doute bien mais ils ont
fait comment on va simplement déjà se
poser dans le corps et mon premier
conseil vous observez votre respiration
vous prenez une ou deux grands
inspiration par le nez et vous allez
vraiment sentir ce qu'il faut alors
attendez tous ensemble alors on respire
la grande inspiration et observer ce qui
se passe dans votre corps en gros
[Rires]
deuxième conseil alors bien dormi alors
bien dormir ça oui il paraît qu'on a
perdu nombre d'heures de sommeil j'étais
impressionné par par les chiffres on
dort en moyenne ou les Français 6h30 par
nuit c'est pas suffisant on a perdu des
heures de sommeil on a perdu des heures
de sommeil en quelques années peut-être
que le chiffre j'ai pu en tête pour tout
vous dire oui 6h30 oui on dort 6h30
c'est ce que je viens de dire mais avant
de dormir davantage dans l'oreillette
6h30 on m'écoute même pas quand je parle
en plus
je crois deux heures de sommeil en
quelques décennies un peu plus en 40 ans
on a perdu à peu près deux heures de
sommeil en France ce qui est une
catastrophe en fait parce que le sommeil
c'est primordial je sais qu'on le dit
tout le temps mais il faut le répéter
c'est comme la respiration pourquoi
parce que dans le sommeil il y a plein
de choses se passer dans le corps déjà
on va récupérer physiquement ça on le
sait mais on va aussi harmoniser tous
nos cycles hormonaux par exemple on sait
que le cycle de la glycémie va dépendre
du sommeil si on dort pas assez on
risque de développer un diabète oui mais
enfin il y a plein de problèmes on a
tous des problèmes parfois pour
s'endormir on se réveille au milieu de
la nuit au hasard arrive à tout le monde
ça qui n'est pas concerné par par les
problèmes de sommeil
et c'est pour ça qu'ils t'ont respirer
d'ailleurs il faut faire moi c'est ce
que je fais quand je me rappelle la
méditation en pleine conscience donc je
respire et en fait j'accepte voilà
j'accepte de pas dormir c'est pas grave
parce que plus vous cherchez le sommeil
moi vous allez le trouver le problème
c'est le mental donner des cours c'est
génial ça m'intéressait tout non mais
c'est vrai en plus
c'est normal de se réveiller la nuit
c'est la rumination
[Rires]
le problème c'est que normalement on va
automatiquement repartir dans un cycle
de sommeil si on fait rien si on observe
simplement la respiration voilà mais on
commence à cogiter on commence à se
faire des choses
c'est pour ça qu'il faut revenir à
l'instant présent avec la respiration
d'accord j'ai pas besoin d'être sur le
plateau vous explique
décidément elle est géniale pratique
mais oui elle pratique mais c'est bien
ça et bon ok alors bien arrêtez de
ruminer aussi
arrêtez de ruminer à tout ce qui va pas
c'est ça parce que le mental en fait va
sans arrêt entraîner du stress chronique
il va nous mettre dans un état de
d'hypervigilance et ce qui va faire
falloir faire déjà c'est s'apercevoir
qu'on est dans les pensées et décrocher
et revenir au corps en parler de
l'instant présent c'est le meilleur
moyen on revient dans la respiration
revient dans le corps et là on sort du
mental pourquoi parce qu'on ne peut
penser qu'à une chose à la fois donc si
vous pensez à votre respiration si vous
pensez à votre corps vous ne serez plus
dans vos pensées mais c'est facile à
dire mais difficile à faire la théorie
non en fait c'est parce que tu te juges
déjà par avance faut pas juger arrête de
juger
arrête de te juger elle a raison Sophie
non mais pas le champagne
avec nous-même et oui il faut accepter
il faut accepter qu'on arrive pas à
dormir il faut accepter qu'on rumine il
faut tout accepter et une fois que vous
acceptez ça vient tout seul j'ai même
une phrase que je dis à mes patients
imagine dites-vous dans votre tête je ne
veux pas dormir mais ils me disent mais
docteur j'arrive pas à dormir je vais
pas me dire en plus je ne veux pas
dormir et ben c'est paradoxal au moment
où on se dit ça notre corps il lâche on
s'endort
vous vous réveillez de la nuit je veux
pas dormir
d'ailleurs c'est le type de votre
bouquin c'est le titre de votre bouquin
sortir versumes ruminations mentale et
ça marche avec je veux pas faire l'amour
pas mal pas mal bon faire du sport c'est
pas voilà le lien pour deux choses déjà
on va recentrer sur le corps évidemment
quand on fait du sport parce qu'on va se
sentir nos muscles mais en plus on va
libérer comme quand on rit des
endorphines qui vont libérer qui vont
nous détendre et qui veulent nous sortir
en fait de l'état de stress pour aller
dans le fameux système parasympathique
le système de la détente ouais c'est
sympa
qui fait du sport pour de vrai hein
[Musique]
j'ai pris ma carte la salle de sport
j'essaie deux fois puis bon bah je fais
du sport j'ai une carte Sophie ouais
j'en fais mais j'en fais vraiment parce
qu'il faut en faire en fait je sais pas
ça je sais qu'il faut en faire donc j'en
fais non je
j'aime bien quand j'ai justement la
récompense la dopamine le truc je me dis
j'ai le sentiment du devant accompli
quoi c'est bien
moi il y a deux jours
il y a de sa fille mais alors le yoga
non non Alexandre moi je fais du sport
tous les week-ends
très physique et je suis totalement
d'accord avec le sport et moi j'appelle
ça virer les mauvaises toxines et j'ai
beaucoup couru et je regrette de de
d'avoir arrêté en fait mais là je vais
m'y remettre
[Applaudissements]
alors moi je fais j'ai repris le sport
c'est bien depuis quand depuis une
semaine
j'essaye de tenir deux fois par semaine
déjà bon c'est bien et sur la console ça
se passe bien
c'est important et puis il y a des
formes simples c'est à dire faire du
sport je plaisante quand je dis la carte
là à la salle de sport mais tout
simplement marcher marche à pied la
marche à pied un peu tonique ça coûte
pas d'argent on peut le faire n'importe
où monter les marches monter les marches
plutôt prendre des ascenseurs c'est un
peu simple mais
c'est vrai
les centenaires et plus de centenaires
en fait ils disent qu'en fait la
corrélation entre tous ces gens-là c'est
qu'ils sont obligés de bouger c'est par
exemple ils sont dans des villages où il
y a des escaliers et cetera donc il y a
pas de sédentarité donc plus on bouge et
plus envie vieux d'accord et moi
maintenant je monte les volets c'est
bien court en fait c'est important c'est
pas l'intensité c'est la longueur d'une
bonne marche vous montez des escaliers
c'est excellent pour le cardio de la
motivation et après ça fait du bien et
puis changer son alimentation et
franchement on a une vie je raconte pas
cet après c'est nul là le sport
il va falloir diminuer l'inflammation
chronique au niveau des intestins donc
on arrête tous les produits qui sont
transformés
et on revient sur des fibres on revient
sur des oméga 3 sur de la vitamine D
alors très concrètement parce que les
films les oméga 3 tout ça c'est super
maman du poisson tout ce qui est de
l'ordre des noix c'est très bien
c'est très bien fait chier allez pêcher
aussi
ça fait du sport en même temps
tu sais bien assaisonné ça passe un
petit peu de piment d'Espelette et basta
ouais non c'est important parce qu'on
est en train de découvrir en ce moment
que l'inflammation des intestins est en
lien direct avec le stress avec
l'angoisse et même la dépression ça veut
dire que notre microbiote c'est tous les
bactéries qui sont dans les intestins
ont un lien direct avec comment on sent
des choses assez en fait
et du coup en fait cette phrase est
assez juste quand on dit qu'on est ce
qu'on mange mais c'est vrai bon alors
quoi du poisson des légumes c'est tout
mais non vous pouvez mettre le chocolat
noir vous pouvez manger des trucs sympas
vous pouvez manger des trucs seul genre
des avocats c'est fun l'avocat non ah
mais je crois que ça faisait grossir moi
non c'est des bonnes graisses il faut du
plaisir à manger éviter vraiment un
message éviter la nourriture transformée
attendez quand on peut pas quand on
court quand on est au travail que il y a
pas un truc aussi sur la culpabilité
genre quand on culpabilise pas on peut
manger plein de trucs et en fait ça va
non il faut aussi enlever l'alimentation
évidemment faut pas être extrémiste mais
si un jour on va manger quelque chose de
transformer le lendemain on va essayer
d'équilibrer un peu plus notre
alimentation bon d'accord ok c'est quoi
votre menu préféré avec Sandra moi McDo
Findus
[Rires]
effectivement
[Musique]
à ton alimentation l'alimentation alors
j'essaie de faire un effort mais en vrai
j'essaie de quand même manger à ma faim
que tout le monde me dit oui quand tu
vas vieillir je peux avoir enfin tout me
fait culpabiliser donc je profite un peu
quand même ouais mais je fais attention
tu dis pas non quoi avec les frites
génial on a le droit de temps en temps
de te hamburger avec des frites maxi
burger avec la petite sauce qui va bien
avec
mais c'est vrai que moi j'ai acheté un
autocuiseur c'est vous mettez tout
dedans c'est génial voilà un peu de
haricots et puis son père on perd un peu
de kilo et si vous enlevez juste les
desserts déjà vous vous sentez vachement
plus libre dans votre corps moi je mange
pas de pain ah c'est bien j'enlève le
parc j'ai enlevé le pain c'est terminé
de temps en temps quand même le penser
c'est bon ça fait des pics de glycémie
le pain c'est très mauvais ah bon le
petit épeautre est pas mal donc voilà
pour changer la farine on sera tout là
parce qu'on peut pas tout changer c'est
impossible on peut pas tout changer on
fait tous les autres on a les enfants et
tout on peut pas leur faire tous les
soirs les associations les poissons
bon courage pour les faire dîner merci
beaucoup d'avoir été avec vous merci à
notre merci marine merci rose merci
Sophie merci
mec tout de suite c'est Cyril Hanouna
pack le jeu et on se retrouve lundi
[Applaudissements]